alright let's get started I'll start a
minute early why not right just to let
people come in so much to talk about I
was not actually going to stream today
but then I saw that my emotes got
approved after like 10 days by twitch so
I figured I'd stream why not and a lot
of people liking the emotes only a
couple people are tier 1 and tier 2 so
they don't get all the emotes but I'm
already seeing the David cry emote I'm
seeing the David chomp emote from
McLovin I'm seeing the David hare and
ideas I guess ideas mixed on the ideas
one I guess it's like jokingly any time
I mentioned the Battle of ideas that one
could be used to be honest I don't even
really know whether these are supposed
to be used in concert with something I'm
doing or not but I guess it doesn't
really matter but anyway the emotes are
there so I am here and it's great to
finally have the emotes there and I'm
guessing that now we will be able to
iterate now that there are emotes we
will get better and better emote so one
of the things I'm going to do in a bit
I've been thinking about doing this for
a while I'm going to take some different
political quizzes that are around so one
is this new New York Times one let us
predict whether you're a Democrat or a
Republican of course I'm neither but I
am on the left for sure we'll see if it
predicts that I've done the I side with
quiz and the political compass quiz
already a bunch of times so I don't
think I'm gonna do that again
let's firt got some others though that I
might do there's the eight values one
and then there's politicals but these
are sort of long but I'll talk about
what people want me to do people saying
that there is a sync issue let's try to
fix that but but please first refresh
your page refresh your page first I
don't want to go chasing a sync issue
that's not really there refresh your
page first and if you've refreshed your
page and there's still a sync issue let
me know because it looks like a hundred
and million 50 millisecond offset was
what fixed it last time and I don't want
to start fixing it again if it's not
really a problem so please only tell me
whether there's an issue in the chat if
you refreshed your page sink is fine
still out of sync good it's fine a
little bit of a sink issue okay it seems
like there might be a small sink issue
can can people tell me whether should I
be adding to the 150 or taking what
taking away from the 150 I think I'm
fine doing another tweak but I don't
want to make it make it worse in the end
it's the video is behind the audio so
you're hearing it first so does that
mean do I need to go up from 150 or down
from 150 the videos behind the audios
ahead it's better sync is only good sync
is fine for me
hmm it seems fine to me yeah maybe I
don't do anything with it right now it's
it's unclear there doesn't seem to be a
consensus video is slightly behind it's
fine okay well I'm doing nothing then
I'm gonna do nothing okay also I have a
hard out at 8 p.m. today because I have
a phone call at that point so I've set a
very modest goal of just 10 website
members to open the phones the phone
lines have been going really well
info is over there for signing up on my
website that's the most direct and
precise way of supporting my work zero
of 10 website members 10 is a very low
goal we should be able to easily hit it
and then I'll open the phone lines for
you fine folks a little bit later and by
8 p.m. Eastern sorry I forgot I have to
mention timezone I would add another 75
milliseconds people are saying you know
what I'm gonna add 50 milliseconds I
don't know if this updates instantly it
seems to I've just added 50 milliseconds
let's let's let it go okay people are
saying I should raid when done streaming
today yes I want to raid someone please
tell me who I should raid because if the
people that I follow let me see if
anyone I don't really follow that many
people let me see if anyone's even
streaming right now destiny is streaming
and that's it I guess I could
conceivably rate destiny at the end of
this but we'll see if anyone else is
streaming by the time I'm done
raid Hasan or destiny raid a cute girl
to flex your clout that's an idea
actually you know there is actually a
girl streamer whose name I forget who
has like a ton of followers who follows
me on Twitter and I have no idea if she
even knows I'm streaming but I think I
think she does like Minecraft or
whatever I don't even know who it is
pokey main yes that's exactly it that
that is the person but I don't even
follow her on Twitch so I think I should
right since she follows me pokey main
let me follow here pokey main is live
that's interesting someone should let oh
wow 3.2 million followers that's insane
someone should definitely let pokey may
know that I very much appreciate the
follow on Twitter and that I am I have
since started streaming on Twitch and
it's all very exciting okay the other
thing is I put the chat up and for I
don't know why it's this theme it's
really strange but I was hoping it would
be sort of like a transparent background
people said it's not bad to have the
chat up for what I upload these to
youtube but I don't know why it looks
that way I didn't mean to set that theme
and I don't see any theme is being set
but maybe somebody can contact me and
tell me how to just change the
appearance of that widget when I open it
up under theme yeah it just says clean I
don't know it doesn't really look there
now I just changed something and now it
looks a little bit different but there's
all this empty space this is so weird
yeah anyway I maybe somebody can help me
out with that maybe someone can help let
pokey main know that I'm streaming and
all of that stuff okay so let me get
started with these quizzes and we'll see
how we do with them let me see if there
was anything else to mentioned
I mentioned the emotes are live I will
try to remember to raid someone if you
have Amazon Prime and you're new to
twitch know that you get a free twitch
Prime membership because of your Amazon
Prime membership and that is a paid
membership for us so please subscribe to
my channel on twitch with twitch Prime
it doesn't cost you anything it sends us
some money and I should thank people who
have done that already a green man 137
gifted a tier 1 sub to Dylan here 100 I
appreciate that Panda Pam kah subscribed
with twitch prime thank you Chris night
arts subscribed with twitch prime I
appreciate that
has she messy I appreciate the twitch
Prime subscription MF Kool Aid
subscribed with twitch prime and I
appreciate that
the revaita subscribed with twitch prime
and so did Dracula with a twitch Prime
subscription appreciate that very much
thank you
audio is off people are you gotta be
kidding me
yeah I just don't know what's going on
with the with the twitch with the audio
I don't know if it's a twitch based
issue it's fine when I do anything else
but I'm not gonna do anymore I'm not
gonna make any other audio changes right
now website members to be clear are not
twitch members but website members
people seem confused and the info is
right over there and I want to thank
Tyler Rabin who is a website subscriber
number one Rodrigo Clark who is website
subscriber number two and daniel
Hemmerle who is the evenings website
subscriber number three so we are three
tenths of the way there alright so let
me get right into some of these quizzes
this um this first one my dad sent me
and I feel like it's gonna be pretty
short let's take a look are you black
Hispanic or Asian I already don't know
the answer I think I am Hispanic let's
see if we can redefine Hispanic Hispanic
definition in the u.s. census anyway I
mean I don't know let me pull this up in
a second
let's just take a look I believe that I
am Hispanic okay
definition Hispanic or Latino refers to
a person of Cuban Mexican Puerto Rican
central South or Central American or
other Spanish culture regardless of race
okay so I am South American regardless
of race this includes Argentinian okay
so the answer there is I am Hispanic so
that way yes
so just on that basis apparently by
being black Hispanic or Asian its 14%
more likely than even that I would be
democratic so far so good
am i black I don't think I need to look
up the definition for that when I am NOT
black am i Protestant definitely not
Protestant have you or a family member
served in the military I haven't but I
have family members who have but not the
US military what what are what's
people's opinion I have family that have
served in militaries but not the US
military so do I answer yes or no
u.s. military only someone says although
it's not clear probably means u.s. I
would say as any military count
I would assume US military US only I
would say no yes no US military only
here's my thought on this there's a very
particular so in other places like for
example in Israel where I have family
that have served in the military because
everybody serves in the military there's
no like cultural or political thing that
would be associated with serving in the
military because everyone does it I feel
like the context here is that it's
trying to ascertain something based on
American culture around military service
so I think on that basis the answer is
no and people seem to be agreeing with
me so I'm gonna say no and my 42 are
younger yes
is your family income less than 60,000
per year no ok people like you are plus
61 democratic
okay I mean I vote mostly for Democrats
although I'm not a Democrat
although +61 okay but does this mean
anything to anyone I don't even know
though how much we have we learned
anything from this this seems very dumb
I don't think we've learned much from
this at all anyone could have predicted
it people are saying yeah I don't
disagree with you
phrenic 31 has cheered 10 bits and I
appreciate that
Mesmer plague 666 one has subscribed
with Prime and I really appreciate that
as well let me get to some other website
members Jonathan Kirchner Kirchner by
the way we're gonna be talking about
Kirchner tomorrow but my home country of
Argentina is imploding and we will be
taught there will be plenty of
discussions of Kirchner tomorrow on the
program Jonathan Kirchner is new website
member number four of the evening and
the manda Cordero is new member number
five so we are at five out of ten
website members if we get to ten I'll
open up the phone lines okay we have an
option here I can either take the eight
values test which someone suggested to
me or I can take the politicals test
now the politicals test has 117
questions which seems a little bit
insane for just a casual stream the
eight values test has 70 questions so
I'm leaning towards doing eight values
merely because it's shorter what let's
see what people say
politicals one eight values two people
say eight values three four eight values
two for politicals
four five six seven eight for eight
values eight values they okay it looks
like people are saying just to go with
eight values so I will do that okay i'll
politicals will save for a different day
please feel free to play along with me
if you would like and thank you too
za r f-- fifty-five for signing up with
twitch Prime and madam AO madam AO
for subscribing with twitch plot Prime
as well
okay so let me just jump right into this
feel feet free to play along okay people
are talking about slowmode do we have
some kind of slow mode right now slow
mode 30 seconds I guess we don't really
need that I'll turn that down just 10
seconds right now there's not that many
people in the in the chat kind of a slow
stream okay all right let's get right
into it
slow stream not not a prostate issue I'm
just talking about an online thing
all right oppression by corporations is
more of a concern than oppression by
governments I tend to agree with that
although I won't
strongly agree it is necessary for the
government to intervene in the economy
to protect consumers who strongly agree
we've heard this laughable thing about
regular corporations have incentives to
regulate themselves no regulation is
needed that's a complete and total joke
the freer the markets the freer the
people I would disagree but not strongly
with that it's better to maintain a
balanced budget than to ensure welfare
for all citizens strongly this disagree
and the more we learn about about modern
monetary theory the more we learn about
how government spending is differently
stimulative I I just come strongly
disagree with that publicly funded
research is more beneficial to people
than leaving it to the market I think we
need both publicly funded research is
more beneficial than leaving it to the
market
I guess I'm neutral I think we need a
combination and I think what we need to
understand is that leaving leaving
research to the market still depends on
public funding because it's based on the
system of courts that we have to enforce
intellectual property it's sort of an
obscure question yeah as a few people
are saying a lot of the people that are
doing the private market research were
educated by public schools so it's I'm
gonna just say neutral or ensure
international trade is beneficial I
agree I agree with specialization but
again the question is worded sort of
vaguely as a lot of people are pointing
out from each according to his ability
to each according to his needs
we know the history of this I'm gonna
just say neutral I'm sure
it would be best if social programs were
abolished in favor of private charity
disagree although not strongly it would
be great if we didn't need social
programs to begin with but I think we've
seen a lot of reason to believe that we
should not abolish them in favor of
private charity taxes should be
increased on the rich to provide for the
poor so I agree I mean I do agree I
don't agree strongly because I feel like
there's so much lower hanging fruit in
terms of reallocating the taxes we're
already connect collecting but I do
generally agree that on the very very
rich there should be a higher marginal
tax rate inheritance is a legitimate
form of wealth
oh geez I mean listen it's legitimate in
the sense that I don't believe we should
outlaw inheritance is it legitimate in
the sense of you are entitled to every
dollar of it no matter how many tens of
millions or billions of dollars I would
say no so I I would sort of say I'm
neutral on that public utilities like
roads and electricity should be publicly
owned strongly agree easy one excessive
government intervention is a threat to
the economy I believe that if it's truly
excessive it is a threat to the economy
I disagree with a lot of right-wingers
about what it means to be excessive we
would probably disagree
so I'll agree but not strongly with the
idea that hopefully whatever algorithm
evaluates these are accounting for the
nuance let me just say thanks to a
couple of other people as we get into
this ligase has cheered a hundred bits
and I appreciate that very very much and
oh no new website members okay it'd be
great if by the time I was done with
this we had the ten website members and
I could open up the phone lines
Maxo tour has also subscribed for one
month at Tier three
Maxo tour welcome to tier three we have
only how many tier three we have only
two tier three subscribers and Maxo tour
is number two tier three gets you access
to the former producer Louis
emote which is now enabled and live I'm
a website member what are you asking us
to do subscribe via twitch no be a
website member and you've already done
it
organic leafy greens I appreciate that
let's continue those were the greater
ability to pay should receive better
health care disagree I'm totally fine
with those who have more ability to pay
to go out and buy whatever health care
they want or can afford but no quality
education is a right of all people
strongly agree social democracy the
means of production should belong to the
workers who use them I disagree I am NOT
a a socialist although I don't strongly
disagree in that if a corporation wants
to organize that way they should be
allowed to and that's absolutely great
the UN should be abolished disagree I
think strongly disagree military action
by our nation is often necessary to
protect it often what do we mean by
often I mean it quite frankly most of
the military engagements that the US has
gotten involved in in the last many
decades have not been necessary to
protect the nation so I'm going to
disagree I support regional unions such
as the EU I support their right to exist
whether they're beneficial or not is
sort of a question and this is a very
poorly worded question so I'll say
neutral it's important to maintain our
national sovereignty I'll agree but not
strongly I mean I acknowledge and accept
the nation-state as as as a way to
organize the planet so to speak a United
world government would be beneficial to
mankind this is so loaded and I sort of
don't even want to I think that no
matter what I say unless I do neut
neutral or unsure it's all in the
details right there are ways in which a
united world government would better
deal with issues that don't respect
country lines like climate change right
pollution doesn't respect country lines
so I think I'm just gonna say neutral on
that it's more important to retain
peaceful relations than to further our
strength man
I've never taken this before but a lot
of these lack any context whatsoever
it's like it's important to retain
peaceful relations up to the point at
which we start getting taken advantage
of right I mean this is I think my
approach is going to be as people are
saying a lot of these questions are
trash if it's a really bad question I'll
just do neutral unsure Wars do not need
to be justified to other countries man I
guess I disagree with that I think they
do need to be justified if not legally
for the purposes of maintaining
relationships military spending is a
waste of money man it's like it's not a
waste of money like having a military is
not a waste of money the degree to which
we spend on the military is ridiculous
it's yeah really good point el coups
these questions are likely aimed at
people who are just not as informed on
political issues military spending is a
waste of money let me take it like
superficially and literally no military
spending is not a waste of money
international aid is a waste of money no
it's also not a waste of money but it's
often done in ways that don't really
better nations over the long term my
nation is great these types of that
neutral I'm sure research should be
conducted on an international scale I
agree with that I would love to see that
government should be held that should be
accountable to the international
community strongly agree even when
protesting an authoritarian government
violence is not acceptable oh god it's
like I'm against violence there are
circumstances in which a population has
no choice violence is not acceptable I
wish it said is violence is never
acceptable because then I could disagree
with it I guess I'm going with neutral
or I'm sure my religious values should
be spread as much as possible this is
just strongly disagree I'll take a break
at 35 and thank people who have been
signing up our nation's values should be
spread as much as possible strongly
disagree it is very important to
maintain law and order it's important
there are values that in certain cases
would supersede I'll say agree
rather than strongly agree the general
populace makes poor decisions I actually
strongly agree with this and I know that
there is an anti democra anti-democratic
sort of implication in that which is not
the way I say it but it is true that the
general populace makes poor decisions
victimless crimes such as drug use
should not be crimes at all I agree that
drug use should not be a crime a lot of
so-called victimless crimes are not
really victimless but let's assume that
this really is referring to actual
victimless crimes I will agree the
sacrifice of some civil liberties is
necessary to protect us from act of
terrorism some yes some civil liberties
but we go too far and we don't really
protect from civil lip from terrorism so
I guess I would say I'm assuming that
the test is going to rate me like an
adult so I'm gonna say agree all right
let's take a break and thank a few
people Liam
ha mama has subscribed with twitch Prime
and I really appreciate that
King Humpty has subscribed for one month
at Tier one and I also really appreciate
that thank you so much let's see I
believe we have a couple of other new
members here let me see here Pam
Spaulding is a new david pakman show
website member thanks Pam really
appreciate that and Karl Olsen is a new
david pakman show website member so that
gets us to seven out of ten again we are
looking for ten new website members info
is right over there I'll open up the
phone lines if we get those ten website
members let's see here somebody's saying
the test will show I'm a globalist
imperial fascist yes we'll we'll see
let's continue government surveillance
is necessary in the modern world
some surveillance is necessary not what
we actually have terribly worded
question I'm going to say a neutral or
unsure the very existence of the state
is a threat to our Liberty no I disagree
with that seems like a libertarian
talking point regardless of political
opinions it's important to side with
your country I mean I'm not an idiot
strongly disagree no authority should be
left unquestioned I agree the question
is which authority and to what extent
and for what reason a hierarchical state
is best garbage question garbage
question there are definitely we know
from sociology and political science
that there are types of decisions where
you need a hierarchical organization or
things become literally impossible but a
hierarchical state is best it's sort of
a garbage question but I'm just gonna go
neutral it's important that the
government follows the majority opinion
even if it is wrong I actually tend to
disagree with that in some cases the
stronger the leadership the better
stronger as an authoritarian strong man
stronger as in decisive stronger as in
most educated it's just such a garbage
question that I have to go neutral
unsure democracy is more than a
decision-making process agree with that
environmental regulations are essential
strongly agree a better world will come
from automation Science and Technology
so I told Joe Rogan this five years ago
I would have said it strongly agree I
still agree but I'm less of a techno
utopian than I used to be so I will say
agree children should be educated in
religious or traditional values should
it no they can be but I disagree or
strongly disagree that they should be
I guess strongly disagree traditions are
of no value on their own I think
traditions have value sociological II on
their own suggests to me divorced from
their history so I'll say that on their
own they are of no value I'll agree
although it's sort of you know more in
the nuance religion should play a role
in government strongly disagree churches
should be taxed
my other institutions are tax tax I
believe that churches should be taxed
absolutely if they are doing politics
I'm not against there are some
educational components of churches that
are relatively non religious that I'm
okay with not taxing but I mean
basically yeah I agree
climate change is currently one of the
greatest threats to our way of life
strongly agree it's important that we
work as a united world to combat climate
change
strongly agree Society was better many
years ago than it is now I'm gonna
disagree although it's quite a loaded
question in many ways I think society is
better than it has been previously but
also has new problems to solve if that
makes sense
wait today was bet right disagree it's
important that we maintain the
traditions of our past I disagree if
they're not good no need to maintain
them it's important that we think in the
long term beyond our lifespan strongly
agree reason is more important than me
important than maintaining our culture I
agree
although I don't think of culture as
unimportant drug you should be legalized
or decriminalized obviously same-sex
marriage should be legal of course no
cultures are superior to others how
loaded question I think that science can
tell us a lot about the superiority of
certain outcomes and many of those
outcomes relate to culture I'm just
gonna go neutral unsure sex outside
marriage is immoral strongly disagree if
we accept migrants at all it is
important they assimilate into our
culture it is important that they
assimilate to the extent that a total
lack of assimilation causes problems but
we don't want them to assimilate too
much that their culture disappears
because that's what's so great about a
multicultural society so I would say it
is important but I don't strongly agree
in some sense yeah assimilate is such a
loaded word disagree then I guess that
means I disagree okay abortion should be
prohibited in most or all cases strongly
disagree
gun ownership should be prohibited for
those without a valid reason I actually
would like that it it would not be
compatible with the Second Amendment in
the United States
garbage question in terms of the Second
Amendment context so I'm gonna go
neutral
I support single-payer universal health
care strongly agree prostitution should
be illegal I actually disagree I've read
a lot about this issue and there are
good arguments made on both sides if you
really narrow the debate but big picture
I disagree that prostitution should be
illegal if we sort of consider it from
an adult sort of like realistic sense
maintaining Family Values is essential I
mean Family Values as defined by those
who talk about Family Values in the
United States are disgusting I'm trying
to think if there's any way in which I
would agree I think I just disagree to
chase progress at all costs as dangerous
I agree with at all costs but I am about
progress as a progressive so I'm going
to say agree
genetic modification is a force for good
even on humans I agree if done
responsibly I believe it is inevitable
so I believe it is a force for good at
least conceptually although as people
are pointing out it's a loaded question
we should open our borders to
immigration give me a break
does that literally mean we no longer
have borders does it mean we should be
open to more people coming in Legally
completely loaded and I have to be
neutral or I'm sure government should be
as concerned about foreign citizens as
they are about those within the borders
I would word it the opposite way
government should be as concerned about
the people within our borders as foreign
citizens so does that mean I agree like
government should be equally concerned
what do people think
feels loaded the way it's mentioned but
if the question is should governments be
equally concerned
concerned about what yeah neutral
disagree agree that's an agreement yeah
I mean I guess I'll assume that it goes
both ways all people regardless of
factors like culture or sexuality should
be treated equally they should all be
treated equally under the law that
doesn't mean we react to everyone in the
exact same way if you see someone who
for example has a disability it would be
normal to treat them differently in that
you might hold the door for them and
make sure that they are able to get in
or out of a door in a way that you might
not for someone who doesn't have a
disability all people regardless of
factors like culture or sexuality should
be treated equally let's assume this
means under the law I'll say I agree it
is important that we further my groups
goals
above others I mean if you're asking me
about my political group then I agree I
believe my political affiliation is with
those who have the right ideas if you
mean my ethnic group or my nationality
then it's like no just such a terrible
question I'm gonna go neutral okay
before we look at look at the results
let me just see who else I need to thank
here still stuck at 7 of 10 website
members so no phone lines yet let's look
at who else we have here
Nikki 206 has subscribed subscribe dwith
twitch prime Thank You Nikki Great Dane
one two three has cheered a hundred bits
anonymous cheerer has cheered one bit
and Mt maestro has subscribed with prime
really appreciate that thank you very
much okay I'm gonna hit neutral here and
let's see what my results are economic
axis I am more social what okay let's
see equality I'm more for equality over
markets but not overwhelmingly so okay
my diplomatic access is peaceful I am
more I guess this means for thinking
about society as the world rather than
nation civil access I'm liberal I tend
to be this makes sense I've always
thought of myself as
left libertarian I am more for liberty
over Authority not hugely surprising
societal axis I'm very progressive
absolutely socially progressive closest
match social democracy okay let me talk
about this a little bit this is really
good in the sense that I've talked to a
lot of people a lot of friends who say
oh I'm a moderate Republican and then I
asked them questions and like on every
issue there they're clearly on the left
and that's disturbing
because I think that this is actually
really common there's a lot of people
who just don't even understand their own
politics and they end up voting for
politicians whose rhetoric might appeal
to them but whose politics don't and so
I think it's really good for people to
understand what our politics are and I
get people are saying labels or trash
you know who cares about what the labels
are okay whatever I mean maybe the
labels aren't the right ones or whatever
the case may be I believe that I am a
social democrat and this as well as
political compass and others basically
confirm that and only if we actually
understand what our political beliefs
are are we going to be able to go and
then actually figure out who do we want
to vote for so I think that the I'm
pleased that the test is seems accurate
and I'm pleased that I seem to
understand my own politics there when I
took the I side with test it said that I
was a socialist just like Kirsten
Gillibrand and it's like I'm not a
socialist and I didn't think kirsten
gillibrand was a socialist the test
doesn't seem well calibrated this this
may be the best one I've taken what do
people in the chat think is this a few
if people have taken others
Hasaan raid has entered the chat oh is
that right I didn't see that did Hasan
raid me politicals is better maybe I'll
do that when it has way more questions
no oh I see people are using some kind
of hassan ii mode i guess got it
yeah okay so we both owe the moral
foundations by IDR labs
yeah let me make a note of that okay so
people have ideas for next time let me
just make notes so politicals moral
foundations that would be a good one
[Music]
my political compass okay Hassan raid
emote got it
according to bread Tube I'm a fascist I
answered too much neutral says Cubans
soy boy yellow sand I'm not gonna listen
to what a soy boy says so that's just
too bad psychopathy test yeah that's a
good one psychopathy test it would be
great if they tightened up the questions
okay I'm not seeing anything else
immediately relevant in the chat all
right so that is that let me see what
else I wanted to get to today okay
here's something I wanted to get you how
many people in the chat who are watching
right now are not david pakman show
YouTube subscribers right now tell me if
you're not a Youtube subscriber
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 and please don't subscribe yet if
you're not 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27
28 29 30 31 32 33 before 35 36 37 no
point in counting why not how else did
would I know
strawpoll yeah I don't know how to do a
strawpoll okay seems like quite a few
okay that is very interesting because
we've been trying to figure out how much
of the twitch audience we've got about
twelve thousand followers how much of
the twitch audience came from YouTube
and are already YouTube subscribers and
how many people did not that's
interesting well listen please subscribe
to my youtube channel right now let's
actually see how many people we can get
to subscribe right now right as of this
exact moment we have seven hundred and
sixteen thousand three hundred and sixty
two YouTube subscribers I'm gonna give
this like a minute please subscribe on
YouTube and let's see how many we can
get we're trying to get to a million
we're on track to do it in June that's
only ten months from now so please
consider just right now subscribing over
on YouTube let's see how many we can get
362 you see if i refresh here 385 okay
that's 23 I'll give it a few more
seconds here most people here are
already your subs why a million why a
million would just be awesome for us I'm
not aware of any other left-wing YouTube
channel other than the Young Turks that
currently has a million subscribers and
getting to a million would be huge
people are unsubscribing okay great and
meanwhile my goal is to get the
Instagram I'm sorry the twitch account
to 25% of YouTube
okay so let's actually pull up the
calculator we just launched on twitch a
few days ago like 10 10 12 days ago so
right now we have 12 0 90 divided by
7/16 385 so right now my twitch
following is only one point six eight
percent what it is on what it is on on
YouTube which is sort of sad my thought
is that if we can get to 25 or even 15%
of my YouTube following on twitch that
my twitch will very quickly become like
one of the biggest revenue sources for
us because on YouTube only like
what is it something like point
something percent of the YouTube
followers contribute in any financial
way to us and on twitch it's like 11
percent I mean right now about 11
percent of my twitch followers our
subscribers which is just crazy I mean
if if that was the situation on YouTube
it would be completely bonkers and I
assume that that was gonna fall over
time but as we get more followers on
twitch its continuing right around 11 or
12 percent of my followers are actually
contributing in some way either through
bits or twitch Prime or whatever I do
think that I think it's on the 25th or
the 26th of this month this is going to
drop when a lot of people have their
twitch Prime subs expire and since they
don't renew automatically I'm sort of
predicting that we are gonna have a big
drop in subscribers on the 26th and 27th
which are the one-month anniversaries of
me live streaming for the first time
where we had a whole bunch of followers
so I think that that is maybe maybe a
difference but I'm getting a lot of
messages where people are talking about
no I'm misunderstanding this or the
other some people saying what you need
to understand is that just having 500
people watching live puts you in the top
5% of twitch if that's true that's very
interesting
people saying I'm their favorite girl I
appreciate that thank you so much asking
about what video games I play I don't
really play that money I would have
twice as many followers as his son if I
had a fourth so that seems unreasonable
oh okay I mean yeah some people are
saying it's straight up unrealistic to
think I'm ever gonna get a hundred and
seventy five thousand followers on
Twitch maybe that's true I have no idea
but I'm here to build it so we'll see
what happens
all right let me thank some other people
donkey show cheered a hundred bits great
dane white 123 cheered a hundred bits
say he has subscribed with prime Gerald
Oh Dean has subscribed with prime Great
Dane 123 has cheered another hundred
bits and like eared a hundred bits
persuade has cheered 10 bits which I
also appreciate let's see how we are
doing Oh
on website subscribers nobody knew okay
so listen I'm looking for 10 website
members the infos right there if we get
just three more I'll open up the phone
lines at the top of the hour I've got a
run because I do have a I have a phone
call that I need to phone meeting a work
phone call or whatever you would call
call it so I have not unlimited time but
if we get three more website members
real quick I'll open up the phone lines
this is a five member rebate I don't
know what that means
stream my phone meeting yeah I don't
think so that would not be appropriate
look at YouTube stats through social
blade instead social blade has a ton of
inaccurate info all right I mean never
forgot to refresh let's refresh the
subscriber count'
we started at seven one six three six
two now we are at seven one six four oh
six alright that's pretty good run the
numbers on that seven one six four oh
six seven one six three six two forty
four okay well that's not maybe that
great anyway the whole thing was if you
don't subscribe to me on youtube please
do uh who do people want me to raid when
I am done today
Raj messaged Pakman to go on the show
I've not heard anything from Raj I don't
know who Raj is but people say he has a
huge stream I'm not against going on but
please let Raj know that I have not
heard from Raj and to email me through
my website raid the surfs raid destiny
you know I think what I should really do
is as I mentioned at the beginning of
the of the stream a twitch streamer who
I don't really know that much I believe
who goes by pokey main followed me on
Twitter and now I am on twitch and pokey
main has a million followers and like
3.2 million followers on twitch so I
think I should raid pokey main when I'm
right if pokey Maine were to even if
there's like a 1% chance she would ever
lend me any kind of support on Twitch
it seems worth rating pokey Maine do it
do it do it big-league do it bro all
right so maybe we're gonna do that when
I'm done I will rate pokey Maine let me
make a note of that I'm a noob on this
platform and it's great yeah absolutely
I have no clue what I'm doing but I'm
gonna try it okay we're gonna raid pokey
Maine later very good okay
here's something else I wanted to talk
about I know let me just do a few other
thank-yous extreme moderate cheered 100
bits thank you PQ coyote cheered 100
bits thank you X melancholic melancholic
cheered a hundred bits twice that's two
hundred bits thank you very much I
appreciate that okay fair enough all
right let me talk about something else
people have asked me to address the
prediction markets as a way to
understand the 2020 Democratic primary
the idea being that polls like these on
Real Clear Politics don't tell us nearly
as much about who is likely to win
versus how people are betting so let's
actually take a look at it and compare
let me see how I can do this I can do
this there we go
okay side by side and that doesn't work
yeah okay so let's let's not do it that
way okay so if we look at the opinion
polling right now within the Democratic
primary Joe Biden is doing best at
thirty point eight percent while
Elizabeth Warren has rocketed into
second place followed by Bernie Sanders
if we look at the predicted org markets
we see that Elizabeth Warren has now
jumped ahead of Joe Biden as the most
likely to be the Democratic
followed by Kamala Harris and then
Bernie Sanders so if you are someone who
trusts the polls more which is people
saying how they are going to vote right
now we still have every reason to
believe that Joe Biden is the
front-runner that Elizabeth Warren is
surging that Bernie Sanders is right in
there and Kamala Harris is pretty far
behind on the other hand if you look at
how people are betting we see that
Elizabeth Warren is the person tied with
Joe Biden and actually slightly ahead
that the money is on followed by Kamala
Harris and only later Bernie Sanders so
what do people in the chat think about
this do you do you think that at this
point in time
August of the year before the election
is the opinion polling more likely to
tell us who is going to ultimately be
the nominee or are the prediction
markets more likely to tell us let me
see what people think
polling it's too early polling is more
accurate very inaccurate okay polling
polling polling polling means nothing so
ok listen for people saying polling
means nothing let's actually take a look
at something let me see if I can find
this ok where would that be
let's look at 2016 Republican primary
okay that's not working let me see if I
can find this 2016 Republican primary
polling you may be surprised by this so
let's go back to 2016 and look at the
Republican primary polling ok right now
it's August of 2019 the election is
November of 2020 so in 2016 the
equivalent time was August of 2015 let's
look at August of 2015 here August of
2015
we can even look at the exact date
August 12 2015 Donald Trump was well
ahead in the Republican primary polling
and he was indeed the Republican nominee
in August of 2015 in eventually and he
was leading in August of 2015
okay let's look now at 2016 Democratic
primary polling here it is
if we go back to 2016 and we go back to
August of 2015 which is the equivalent
time to right now August 12th you will
see that Hillary Clinton was well ahead
of Bernie Sanders and of course she was
ultimately the nominee now it got pretty
interesting right here
the point being for the most part in
recent political history the people that
are winning right now end up being the
nominees although again that could
change I know there are lots of people
who are just waiting for Tulsi to
explode or yang to explode and any
second they are going to take the lead I
just don't see it I really don't let me
go back to 2020 presidential here we go
and put it back here I think at this
point the only people who have a shot
are Biden Warren Sanders maybe Harris
and maybe Pete Buddha judge that said I
mean listen bethe O'Rourke is done
Booker is obviously he never wasn't done
Tulsi Gabbard is done
Andrew yang I know people are saying
that he's just jumping up any day now
but I like the guy I've interviewed him
I don't see it nobody else here has a
chance okay so if someone need a lot of
these people aren't even going to make
the next debate let's even look at that
2020 democratic debates wiki this is an
interesting document let me pull it up
here
a lot of these candidates aren't even
going to be in the debates actually
here's an interesting story by the way I
we were scheduled to interview one of
the 2020 Democratic presidential
candidates tomorrow on the show and I
just knew there they're gonna bail soon
people are gonna start quitting they're
gonna cancel on us and they cancelled
today and I assume that they're gonna be
announcing that they're gone
so listen right now you've only got one
two three four five six seven eight nine
candidates who have met the criteria for
the third debate some of these may fall
out Andrew yang for example has four
qualifying polls and you need four if he
loses one of those he's out Castro is
close he has three qualifying polls
Gabbard only has one and I think she's
polling zero in some of these I already
I went away from it but that's let me
see here election 2020 Democratic
nomination Gabbard yeah I mean so she
had I don't even know if economists
YouGov counts but she's polling zero or
one in a lot of these polls so a lot of
these people I mean basically everyone
here
do you even stay in this thing if you're
not in the next debate I don't know what
do people think do you stay in if you
don't even make the next debate stage Oh
people saying you can't lose I thought
that it was I thought that you could
actually lose if more if polls that
happen closer to the event no longer
have you as having two percent support
and maybe I'm wrong about that no so
people are saying you drop out if you
don't make the next debate stay in the
requirements will be easier for the
fourth debate is that right let me take
a look any candidate who qualifies for
the third debate also qualifies for the
fourth debate okay doesn't seem that
it's easier in what sense is it easier
the chat is back to 30 seconds hold time
okay let me see if I can 10-second slow
mode is back on okay no no but I so I'm
not I think there might be a
misunderstanding if you qualify for the
third debate you qualify for the fourth
but I don't know that you have that
period between the third and fourth to
qualify I think it's just if you qualify
for the third year in the fourth but I
may be wrong about that okay in any case
it seems like people are pretty set on
this idea that you should you should get
out okay let me thank a couple of other
people here
electric boogaloo subscribed for one
month at Tier one thank you and I
appreciate that X melancholic cheered
three hundred bits thank you very much
being awesome twelve subscribed with
prime thank you very much
Great Dane 123 cheered three hundred
bits and staring or stereo and ex
subscribed with prime thank you very
very much I also want to say thanks to
oh interesting I want to say thanks
thanks to Chris Bevin Chris Bevin is new
member on my website number eight of the
evening do people want me to take phone
calls this evening if the answer is yes
will two more people sign up on my
website to get us to ten
at which point as the information over
there says that's how you do it I will
open up the phone lines I have until the
top of the hour today because I have a
phone call at the top of the hour I'm
glad to take phone calls from whenever
we get to ten website members until the
top of the hour if people want uh okay
let me see what else we'll be looking at
let's take a final check here so I said
earlier if you're here and you don't
subscribe to my YouTube channel please
do and it seemed like there were a lot
of people forty-four people went over
and subscribed on YouTube let me refresh
once more and see what the current
number is I'll give it like another
thirty seconds please head over to my
youtube channel youtube.com slash the
david pakman show and subscribe it's
free it's literally it cost enough
we're trying to get to a million
subscribers there let me just give it
like 20 more seconds and then we'll see
what our final count is let's see what
else did I want to mention I will be
raiding pokey main when I am done
because she follows me on Twitter and
has 3.2 million followers and it would
just be amazing let me actually I'm
actually gonna tweet to her pokey main
lol okay mean by popular demand I will
be raiding your stream when I'm done
with mine at the top of the hour peace
and love to quote the great Ringo Starr
I don't know what I'm doing but this
maybe is a good thing okay alright let's
do one last refresh over here on YouTube
alright so nothing to sneeze at
I think we've added seven one six four
twenty five seven one six 362 alright 63
of you have gone over and subscribed
over on my youtube channel which I very
much appreciate very very exciting stuff
alright let me see what else I had on my
list here that I wanted to talk about so
we've been premiering the daily TV show
the broadcast show like all these clips
that you see on my You Tube channel are
from my daily TV and radio show we've
been premiering a full episode out of
that on Twitch around 4:30 p.m. eastern
time each day and it's been going okay
what I'm finding is that about 1% of my
twitch followers seem to jump on the
live premieres of my episodes we get a
handful of new twitch prime subscriber
is usually about 50 new followers do
people think that it's worth doing that
every day or should we not be premiering
our TV episodes on Twitch my thought is
just to get more content on Twitch if
and until I do more streaming people
seem to be saying keep it going
I got like tube emails over the weekend
that kind of bummed me out that said
David what you're doing is pointless you
shouldn't premiere that it's a waste of
time people ask me if it
costs anything it doesn't cost anything
just a little bit of time to set it up
structure is good for twitch doesn't
twitch have a rule about recording
content on its platform originally I
don't believe so my twitch contacts said
as long as we're premiering it on twitch
before it goes on YouTube that it's okay
people saying it's good for the time
being feels like good exposure it's
never a waste of time premiere it you
get more viewers yeah I mean listen if
it keeps getting like 1% of my followers
and that number keeps going up it seems
worth it people saying they don't get
notifications for the premiere yeah I
don't even know how people hear about it
quite quite frankly I don't know how it
is that people are finding out about it
but only so maybe maybe that's the
problem right what about YouTube's
feeling on twitch first I don't think
YouTube has anything like that seems
like the benefits outweigh the costs it
does seem that way I prefer watching on
twitch over YouTube but I've been
watching YouTube a long time you're
building a channel and then go live
after the show you build your twitch
base very fast yeah all right well
listen I mean it doesn't seem like
there's any particular reason to stop
doing it at this point
thanks to division who subscribed with
prime let me check last time I forgot to
check my stream labs notifications for
donors over there and I missed a bunch
of comments that people had let me take
a look ok who else here X melancholic
said I'm an e girl tipping your stream
while my streamers tip me ped spread the
streamer love ok spreading like I said
just an anecdote but the gang game
grumps have 5.1 million on YouTube and
only two hundred and thirty two thousand
on twitch so five percent is a good
ratio to shoot for yeah that's fair I
mean maybe I should be shooting for five
percent of my YouTube following on
Twitch which right now would be about
thirty five thousand subscribers maybe
maybe that's reasonable I don't know ash
the straw hat donated two bucks and said
hey David what's your favorite emote on
twitch so far I have no idea I mean I
just I really
pay such little attention to emotes I
should probably pay more attention to
that but I just don't have I done the
political test already yes I have I have
done that already how many subscribers
do I have since joining twitch I don't
know if I'm am I allowed to say how many
subscribers I have I don't want to do
anything that might get me banned a
night meny has subscribed with prime I
appreciate that
people saying it's fine to say it it's
public knowledge but I'm not allowed to
say what percentage we get
okay got it I'm not supposed to yeah
okay so we've got almost 1400 paid
subscribers right now on 12,000
followers which like I said is right
around eleven twelve percent which is
unbelievable I mean truly it's shocking
as a percentage link to the test the
test was eight values results so you go
to eight values github I uh and for
people who missed it I came away as a
social democrat and which is correct I
have a good assessment of my own
politics and the eight values test seems
to correctly assess them as well great
dane 123 has cheered four hundred bits
appreciate that great dane zest
twenty-four has subscribed with prime so
we've actually we may soon have some
challengers for the top Cheers
turkey bacon and cheese is still the top
cheer of all time with 6,500 but there
are a whole bunch of people now between
1000 and 1600 who may soon make it into
the top three which is cool
frank 486 has subscribed with twitch
prime which i also very much appreciate
bernie has a twitch channel alright well
good for bernie okay a todd burr camper
burke amber burke emperor has subscribed
on my website that gets me to nine of
ten website subscribers okay i have like
a half hour left before I have to go and
I am
one website member away from getting to
ten at which point I will open up the
phone lines at six one seven eight three
zero forty seven fifty I say let's just
do this clearly at least some people
want to call in let's let's just get
that one more member and I mean I I
think I'm so confident we're going to
get one more person signing up on my
website I believe we'll actually get
five more that I'm going to go over and
start getting set up to unblock the
phone number not doing it yet but I will
do it soon and when that happens I will
also update the stream title to include
the phone number
[Music]
don't break Pakman don't break
I believe me I am NOT I will only go to
the phones if and when we actually get
ten website members do tier two and Tier
three subscribers count as website
members no unfortunately not only
website members count as website members
isn't pokey main a conservative oh god
is that true if that's true I'm gonna
have to bail holy crap that would not be
good
I'm not finding anything about that or
people just know she's a centrist pokey
main likes contra points I doubt it very
much she's a communist she has said
profit is theft pokies are progressive
okay alright whatever so let's see I
think we have one more new member here
yes Joseph REE Joseph REE is new member
number ten of the evening all right we
have done it so let me get my headphones
on and let me unblock the phone number
the phone lines voicemail off okay
the phone number is six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty six one
seven eight three zero 4750 just gonna
take me a minute to get my headphones on
and to get connected to the system
let's see here got to turn that down so
I don't blow out my eardrums and let me
get connected here 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 now
everything's completely tangled I must
have punched my mic a bunch of times I
apologize okay let's see here what on
earth there's some very strange noise in
my headphones okay and also I need to do
one more thing let's see 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 don't forget that let me just take
care of I'm on the wrong screen for
getting two phone calls my office looks
like a therapists office it is I'm
actually a therapist part-time no I'm
kidding ok let me just add some just
getting everything properly set up do
you have to be a member to call no
anyone can call 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 I've
already got what is it about 10 people
holding right now so let's now get
connected thank you for calling in to
the David Pakman show please do not use
speakerphone have your question ready
something's not working but they're all
out your area code okay I think we're
good
we are very very close to ready to take
phone calls here all right six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty is
the number let me make sure that I am
taking copious notes about the caller's
bad connections may get you blacklisted
between now and the next time I take
calls good questions good connections
getting right to your question or
comment seen very very favorably and in
the meantime let me thank Daniel severe
or thigh verge who has also signed up on
my website as well as Ryan wozmak who
has signed up on my website thank you so
much really appreciate the support and
we are going to take some phone calls
here okay let's go first to the caller
from the 503 area code who's calling
today from 503 oh dear this is not good
hold on a second I know the audience can
hear you but I can't which is a real
problem so just give me one second
headphones
okay can you still hear me yeah I can
hear you okay perfect now you're in my
headphones alright what was your name in
the Portland area what's going on Chris
so just a couple things I know that
you're in the Boston area I first heard
you on W hav it used to be a nonprofit
the wave you know back in 2013 I don't
think they're still around any longer
but that's where I first heard you my
comment though is on the YouTube
algorithm you've been saying on a lot of
your content lately that it seems like
your channel is kind of being minimized
as it were and going to the more kind of
corporate channels and I've noticed that
myself I know the autoplay used to just
kind of go it's like a newer video of
yours now they're going to like each Bo
with John Oliver or they're going to
like more more corporate shows so it's
definitely still a thing and I hope that
that will change alright very good thank
you for the report and yes every
indication that that is the thing
hello all right looks like Chris got in
and out there let's go next to our
caller from the seven-one-seven area
code who's calling today from seven one
seven
hey this is Adam from legacy hey Adam
what's going on not too much just wanted
to keep things light I was wondering do
you do any impressions especially like
political impression no not really
I mean they're all pretty bad I've done
I'm trying to think who I've done I did
I've done some over the years but
they're just not really very good you
know all right all right well thanks for
taking call anyway and uh love watching
your content so all right thank you
appreciate it appreciate it very much
okay let's go to Brody from Dallas Brody
from Dallas it's been a little while
since we heard from him what's going on
Brody hey David it's good to hear from
you thanks bigger than my call I'll get
through it
my question is I was thinking about
electability and turnout as obviously we
need to make sure we maximize that I
wanted to get your thoughts on which
candidates or in general what candidate
that is selected might have on different
effects in terms of down ballot support
meaning if we get a candidate that
people is very energized about say maybe
Bernie or Warren or gang or one of those
candidates versus a candidate that
people are not as excited about like
maybe fight would that have any effect
or any non effect on down ballot
candidates of course yeah I mean whoever
whoever gets more people out to vote is
going to also have a down ballot effect
on other ballots it's only a fraction
you know there will still be people who
go out and vote for president and just
don't feel anything in for down ballot
races that's always the case but there's
no question that just as a it's a
mathematical reality so to speak that
whoever gets the biggest turnout for
their election is going to also generate
more votes for down ballot races and is
there any any evidence or any way we
could maybe like to learn
search more about that because I've been
trying to find information about which
candidates other than just general
turnout have had the most influence on
down ballot candidates and I haven't
been able to find much information about
that do you have any thoughts about the
current field and which candidates might
have a better chance at creating the
enthusiasm to turnout that effect we
need four downs oliday no I mean this
this is this is the whole point which is
we don't know who is most likely to get
the biggest turnout every year we always
hear oh this time young people are
really going to turnout or this is a
candidate who has more of a following
from this group versus that one the only
things that are sort of steady over time
are that older groups of voters are much
more reliable voters than young people
no matter what it is that we hear and
then beyond that it's going to be a
combination I mean listen I think this
election in total is going to come down
to get out the vote and that comes
before presidential and it comes for
house of representatives it comes from
it accounts for what happens in the
Senate as well so no I don't have any
particular insight into that right now
right well that was just a question and
thanks for getting all the hard work you
did Pat and Max and everybody else thank
you so much all right Brody thank you
great to hear from Brody from Texas
let's go to our caller from the nine one
nine area code next who's calling today
from nine one nine what this is diven
it's Steinman diamond yes okay Oh Simon
what's going on Simon I have a question
and that is what our tax is not based on
the result right so wouldn't a more
palatable tax be whatever percentage it
takes from the top whatever percentage
it is to serve whatever that dollar
value heat is for the particular year
for instance education if it cost a
million bucks and you charge whatever
percent it takes from the top 1% to pay
for education yeah are you talking about
the the I don't even understand you so
you're saying first you figure out the
budget and then on that basis you figure
out what is the amount of tax revenue
that you need to take in in order to
cover that exact amount and then you
take no more right that was the other
way around like a trailing
so the previous year's expense you pay
for with this coming years taxation well
I mean we we run a net we what we run a
budget deficit so number one that's just
not the way that it works we take in
less than what we're spending so first I
guess you would need to cut spending and
of course that's like a big right wing
talking point about talking I just don't
I just don't know that I I guess I
generally understand what you're saying
but I don't know in practice what you're
actually proposing I guess for a
particular cause right so pre-k funding
we need to increase K funding who we'd
not say some percent from some percent
you don't want a sliding scale whatever
it takes to pay for that particular need
that's basically what we have I mean we
take a different percentage based on
income from people in order to pay for
the things that we pay for but it's not
a function of the cost of it either all
right well in some in some sense it is
but we deficit spend so it's going we're
spending way above Beyond and beyond
that in order to make up for that we'd
either need to drastically cut spending
or increased tax revenue got it thank
you yeah all right no problem I'm not
sure I totally understood it but I did
my best
let's go next to our caller from the
to12 area code who's calling today from
- one - hi David this is Joseph Henry
yes I can't Joseph what's going on oh
great um so my question kind of centers
around non-interventionism I think that
our foreign policy that we've
implemented in the United States it's a
little bit screwed up at this point in
particular the way that we'd go about
funding it so it seems to me that
there's always this dollar for dollar
sort of alliance between the Republicans
and the Democrats where if you increased
investing spending by $1 you must offset
it with a dollar of increased spending
for some sort of military intervention
intervention so my question is kind of
how can we inform a base of people first
of all can we challenge that idea and
come to a position where military
spending should kind of equal what the
presence of an external or internal
threat to our national sovereignty or
security is and then in addition to that
in an area that's so complicated for the
person who you know works forty-four
hours a week maybe as a family gets
involved in their community in their
church wants to keep up to date on the
latest Netflix show how can we get that
sort of person excited about the
prospect of non-interventionism
especially given the fact that it's
seemingly turned to be unpatriotic to be
against regime change okay so there's a
lot of different stuff in there I mean
first you're talking about military
spending and tying it to domestic
spending then you're talking about
getting through to people the idea that
being against regime change is not
unpatriotic up so there's a few
different things I mean one thing is we
need to right now the status quo on
defense spending is that the debate is
not over cutting defense spending or
increasing it it's about increasing it
more quickly at the same speed or at a
slower speed and like until we get away
from that paradigm I don't know how we
even have any more serious conversations
about the defense spending piece the
other thing is more of an ideological
thing I think increasingly more and more
people understand that the regime change
decisions the regime regime change
involvement that the United States has
had has been disastrous often
financially and militarily for the
United States and also for the countries
in which we're involved in the regime
change so I think that there are
actually a lot there are tens of
millions of people in the country who
get that being against regime change is
not unpatriotic but you still have the
neo cons that are all about it and often
for personal gain sure I mean I think
I'd even go so far to say that it
extends further than that of the neo
cons if you look at particular what's
been happening with tolsey gathered in
relation to how the mainstream media
seems to be attacking her for you know
maybe meeting with a foreign leader and
what the implications of that may be and
there seems to be some sort of
implication that she is less patriotic
as me as a result of meeting with a
foreign leader no I don't think that the
reason she's been criticized is just the
meeting I think it's been the funding of
the meeting playing coy about who
organized the meeting and quite frankly
I mean there's not even been that much
discussion about it because Tulsi
gabbard's polling like one
I think she's polling zero in a recent
poll so I just think that the Tulsi
stuff is overblown I don't think she's
been targeted in it in any particular
way
oh sure III just I mean I mean in terms
of the percentage of her so clearly
she's not pulling too well and so she
doesn't get much time to speak and by
the way I'm not even a totally average
supporter but in terms of when I do see
her on these sort of programs they
almost immediately go towards that issue
rather than addressing anything else
about her campaign and so I mean this
not so much as a criticism of or you
know support of Tulsi Gabbard would
rather criticism of mainstream media
right and and and they're kind of
fervent belief that we need to push
regime change and so I just I guess one
way I could put is I want to thank you
and other outlets out there who are not
in the mainstream in that sort of way of
thinking that kind of promote I think a
more polished and nuanced view of
foreign policy all right thanks for
taking my call Josie Thank You shade
that great to hear from you thank you so
much okay let's go to our caller from
the four one six area code who's calling
today from four one six hey David it's
RJ from Toronto how are you doing hey RJ
how are you I'm good thanks they might
come through clear you're coming through
crystal clear
awesome awesome so my question is about
you VI and Andrew Yang's campaign now
I'm when you're Canadian listeners I
actually grew up in court the lakes
where Ontario had a ubi pilot project
yeah and that project was cancelled
before any data could be harvested
because we have a Conservative
government that won the recent election
here but what I noticed and what you
know my family noticed and what the the
municipality noticed and lobby for was
there's a lot of economic anxiety was
listed so my thoughts are basically that
we have a lot of the other programs that
the Democrats in the States would like
to see implemented but we have some of
the similar economic anxieties here and
ubi addressed that so I wanted to know
do you get the sense like I do that
yang's policy might be better to it
economic anxiety from some of the other
platforms or do you think the other
platforms will do just as well which
other platforms specifically I think we
just have to look at two policies and
compare them well then let's let's go
with Bernie because he's like the
progressive from vonner right well
listen I mean I think there's it's hard
to compare one specific policy like
Andrew Yang's ubi with Bernie's
overarching economic policy I think that
the I have no problem with yang's ubi I
think originally he had it where the
thousand bucks a month was instead of
some of the other benefits that were
available I think he's changed that and
now it's additive and that makes more
sense to me I'm fine with ubi and I
think that it's a great thing to do it's
just not going to fundamentally change
many of the underlying structural issues
in our economy like it's not going to do
anything for inequality because
everybody just gets a thousand bucks
period so like literally it's exactly
what we have now but everyone has a
thousand more dollars a month it's not
going to change the relationships that
exist between employers and employees in
a direct way other than it may give
employees a little bit more negotiating
power in that by making them a little
bit less desperate by having an extra
thousand bucks a month maybe they would
hold out longer for a higher wage that's
possible but on the back end it also
gives another thousand bucks a month to
people to spend at these same businesses
so my real criticism has just been that
it's a reasonable band-aid it is a
band-aid it's a reasonable band-aid but
we still need much broader systemic
change okay so so I guess what so I
suppose what you're saying is you guys I
might be in a privileged position here
in Canada we have some of the
progressive programs that you guys would
like to see implemented in the state
yeah so in that case do you think that
those are probably the priority for you
guys to alleviate those economic
anxieties first well it depends which
programs you're talking about I mean I'm
thinking specifically a Medicare for all
but yeah I mean Medicare for all that's
here that's a huge thing everybody
having health care would be hugely
stimulative in
anyways you know healthier people work
more and generate more wages and earn
more tax revenue and reduces crime you
know that that's that's a that that's
low-hanging fruit in a sense but also
it's extremely difficult to actually get
done in the United States all right yeah
yeah I mean I agree enough you know I
love all the stuff you're doing on
Twitter so appreciate it and keep up the
good work all right thank you for the
call very much appreciate it
let's go next to our caller from the 4-3
to area code who's calling today from
four three two end with me that is you
yeah who's this that's exciting
okay so this is Josh from Texas here I
had a two questions that are very
similar
there's all the talk right now about
Texas going blue Texas going blue and
it's like mmm we keep hearing about
Texas going blue and doesn't really you
know it's we keep getting teased with
this and so I think one of the big
issues with that is immigration is still
seen as anything that is like anything
that is uh basically it's the open
borders talking point ok so I'm
wondering like what what is the what
what can we tell people in Texas who are
worried about open borders no one is
calling for open borders I mean just
literally mine is gone that's what you
have to tell and when they say when they
say it you say who is calling for open
borders what have they said I mean
that's just it just get them to have to
tell you what it is because nobody's
doing it right but there's like this
sense of you say oh nobody you know this
is a straw man nobody is like nobody's
calling for that but every time they go
on the debate stage and they talk about
decriminalizing that makes everybody
think oh they just want to let everybody
roam free yeah ok so you're bringing up
a good point which is whatever your view
on decriminalizing border crossing there
are ways to just I mean listen if
Democrats want to start focusing on you
know free health care for undocumented
immigrants I think that there is a very
significant economic
making moral case to be made for that
but it is a losing argument for
Democrats nationally and I think that
they did they just need to stay away
from that and this that's one way in
which the debates were hugely slanted
towards sort of Republican talking
points as the foundation of the
questions and I think you are right that
even though no one is calling for open
borders there are ways to talk about
immigration and ways to focus on it that
aren't particularly good for Democrats
nationally yeah it's just whatever you
say it's just it's interpreted as oh
they're gonna be weak on the border they
don't care about our protection yes like
you have to have a certain strong
rhetoric otherwise it's you know there's
some skepticism of mmm they're gonna be
weak and they're not gonna really put
our interest first yeah well I think
Democrats just need to do a better job
of understanding what are and are not
voting issues and sometimes there are
non voting issues on which Democrats
will focus which can only potentially
hurt them and you've got to stay away
from them right okay and there was a VP
who do you think that would help bring
Texas along and turning blue
no idea not God I have not I've given no
thought so far to any VP stuff I I tend
to take it one step at a time and III
wouldn't be able to answer that yeah and
what what do you think about Texas going
blue I think like is not exactly in the
presidential 2020 but I think Texas is
an important target for the left in
election cycles to come absolutely okay
all right thank you I appreciate it
let me say thanks to some new twitch
prime subscribers wowie-zowie 462 has
subscribed with twitch prime Titanic
u.s. Gardens has subscribed with twitch
prime and cheered a hundred bits and
galactic 51 has subscribed with twitch
prime target has subscribed with twitch
prime if you're new here and you're new
to twitch and you have Amazon Prime you
can subscribe with twitch prime for free
to you it counts as a paid subscription
for me okay cost you nothing subscribe
with twitch prime using the purple
button up there cost you nothing we get
paid okay great great great stuff I
incur
to do that let me go next to the caller
from the 907 area code who's calling
today from 907 ya sorry what did you say
your name was
Oliver Oliver what's going on Oliver hey
so I was just wondering what you thought
in general of soda taxes or syntax yeah
I've done a couple of interviews about
this and I've done a few segments about
it I believe that as a general thing
economic disincentives do work when
you're trying to encourage or discourage
a particular activity my concern with
some of the taxes that have become
popularized recently is that they work
but they disproportionately punish
people who are least able to sort of are
least able to bear that punishment and
are more economically unstable and that
is a concern to me so like the soda tax
disproportionately affecting bodega
owners versus large supermarket chains
as an example but I don't have a problem
in principle with the government
identifying activities that have a net
negative effect on society like smoking
cigarettes for example or even driving
around a lot and putting gas taxes on I
don't have a problem with it in
principle it's just got to be done right
yeah does that make sense to me I didn't
really think about it from the business
owner standpoint but like if you look at
sodas are cigarette taxes I believe they
don't tend to prevent current smokers
they don't tend to make turn so smokers
stop smoking they tend to prevent new
people from picking it up and so it I
think over time it might like be a net
positive yeah there's a lot of
literature on this which is what I would
go to rather than speculating because
this has been studied quite a bit mm-hmm
all right thanks okay thanks appreciate
the phone call very much thanks to say
he for gifting five tier one sub
to my community cats in the walls got a
free sub gentleman QB a meal two four
six four hairy barnacles and thunder
bear 321 free subscriptions very very
exciting and thanks to Dan X underscore
for subscribing on Twitch prime as well
rollin bear 89 says I get random spikes
of stereo to mono sound not sure if it's
the streams but only happening here is
anyone else getting that I'm not seeing
anything that suggests that should be
happening and I have no reason to think
I'm not getting it same here yes same
here me nope yes yep a few times
anybody know whether that might be a
twitch thing cuz I don't if only so if
it's only happening to some people then
it's hard to imagine it's the equipment
no we don't know only happens here not
on other twitch streams you know there
was a weird thing happening during my
discussion with destiny the other day
where my mic was actually cutting in and
out and I wonder if it's related maybe I
should get a new mic cable or maybe I
should get a new mic altogether or maybe
try a different USB port I don't know
let me just let me just try I'm just
gonna move the mic to a different USB
port real quick hold on
a sting testing one two one two testing
one two one two
I'm back
anybody beto its - that's interesting it
is way louder on that other USB port I
moved it from a USB port labeled SS to
one not labeled SS and people are saying
that it sounds better interesting okay
alright well listen I actually I said
I've got a phone call at the top of the
hour so it's gonna be it for me today I
will be streaming tomorrow night 6:30
p.m. Eastern Time hope to see you there
thanks to everybody who joined me today